The joe rogan experience.
We didn't talk about this the last
time and this was something that was
controversial after our podcasts because
during the manhood training camp,
your dad died.
Right.
How hard was that man to go through?
My Dad and I had like a weird relationship
went dead and I had like a falling
out probably
10 or 12 years ago.
I hadn't spoken 10 years.
And uh,
uh,
he came to one of my fights,
when I've won a glory 10 with arts and 11.
And uh,
was one of the biggest things
that Vinny helped me work on it.
I found out my dad had cancer and like
my reaction when my brother and sister
told me it was like fucking like,
I don't care.
Like it didn't really didn't care.
He didn't that much that a
wow that uh,
I was just like hated them.
Like we had like a really bad issues.
And uh,
uh,
when I started talking to Vinny,
you know,
I mentioned,
yeah,
my dad had cancer and I didn't know how
I felt about it because part of be like
carried,
you know,
at some point.
And Vinny,
uh,
did some,
like a,
he called a timeline
therapy and we had the,
uh,
this is not at all I was
planning on talking about,
but,
um,
we,
uh,
he asked me all of these scenarios like,
think of a time in your life when you
were really proud and then think of a time
when you were really upset and like all
these different emotions and he didn't
know what he was,
what it was about or
what was going to happen.
He's just trying it on in every,
one of the things they
talked about was my dad.
Like every one of those
times was a time with my dad.
And,
uh,
he did like the,
you know,
the whole session or whatever.
At the end of it,
I just had no more resentment or anger
towards my dad and it was really weird.
And,
uh,
it was like this chip on my
shoulder like my whole life.
And,
uh,
at one point for a long time.
Uh,
I used to think about my
dad before I would fight,
when I was fighting professionally.
Like I would use,
not necessarily like I'm fighting my
dad but like to shove it up his ass.
Like,
look what I'm gonna do,
you know?
And,
uh,
I realized that like,
that anger that I had and that I've used
to tap into all the time was actually
like coding me back and
was almost like a handicap.
And uh,
yeah.
When I,
when he helped me forgive my dad,
I was able to,
uh,
go to Florida as,
you know,
he's just got stage four cancer,
he's going to die.
And,
uh,
I had a relationship with my dad for the
last year before he died that I hadn't
had in 10 years and that was from
that Vinnie helped me do that.
That's got to have a big impact on
the way you raise your own sons.
Yeah,
for sure.
Knowing the resentment that you had
towards your father and the anger and the,
the bad relationship,
like never wanting it
to get to that place.
Yeah.
It was,
it was weird,
it was a,
you know,
Vinny didn't know that he was,
that that was even going to be
the result and he was just like,
oh,
I want to try this timeline
therapy thing on you.
And uh,
yeah,
I went from like completely hating
him to like just can forgiving him
completely,
not like halfass for giving him
to like waiting for that apology.
Like there was no apology.
There was no talking about it.
It was like completely starting over.
And uh,
yeah,
we had like a really good
relationship for that
last year before he died.
And,
um,
I knew that he was,
he was battling cancer.
My brother started treating him.
He was stage four.
I mean,
it was the doctor's like,
you know,
as your dad's going to die,
he had cancer and as long as cancer in
his brain cancer in his chest and she
cancer in his neck,
he had like this giant mass.
I was neck.
And,
uh,
my brother started treating
him with CBD oil and,
uh,
allegedly I was shipping it to him
from here and to Florida or whatever.
But that was probably wasn't very good.
It allegedly,
allegedly there was fiction for
Fisher friction operational purposes.
Um,
and we,
uh,
we're giving them CBD oil for about,
I don't know,
I guess seven months probably.
And,
uh,
after,
um,
he wasn't going to chemo,
he just didn't want to do it.
He was like really stubborn.
I'm stubborn.
Guy wouldn't do that.
And uh,
they,
uh,
they tested him,
they did like a graph or whatever to see
where the cancer had grown or whatever
period of time.
And they were shocked that
90% of the cancer had died,
that there was 90% of the cancer was
dead and 10% of the cancer that was still
alive was like completely surrounded
in dead cells so that they couldn't get
even medicine to it and it couldn't grow.
And it was just gonna he was
gonna have to live with it,
you know,
but it was completely
surrounded by dead cancer cells.
And the only thing possibly that could
have done it was the CBD oil because he
was doing nothing else correctly.
He was like,
um,
you know,
they had them on so many narcotics
and pain pills and stuff that he was,
he's a asshole to be around.
It was really hard.
It was like constantly
on like this drug thing.
Um,
and he wouldn't eat.
He only wanted to eat was like
chocolate cake and ice cream,
you know,
like wouldn't,
it was like really hard ad for cancer.
We're like,
we're like,
uh,
you know,
trying to get them to the
right supplements in and,
you know,
it was a,
it was a tough situation,
but the,
uh,
the CBD oil was,
was beating the cancer and the
cancer wasn't what killed him.
He actually died from like starvation
or mount nourishment from not doing what
we would beg him to do really well.
90% of the cancer was dead CBD oil people.
It really works.
Working right now from my friend's mom,
my friend's mom has stage
four cancer and her brain,
uh,
I allegedly got them some CBD oil and uh,
he,
um,
got it to his mom.
Uh,
within less than two months,
her cancer had shrunk by 30% that she
had been doing chemo and they were saying
that her immune system was
so devastated by the chemo,
the chemo is probably going to kill
her quicker than the cancer was.
And they'd recommended her stopping
chemo and he was just in full desperation
mode.
My friends,
real super straight edge,
he just,
he's just,
you know,
Mr Republican American doesn't,
thinks Obama's a Muslim,
that kind of guy and it never would want
to have anything to do with CBD oil or
anything.
Cannabis.
I got it to him and now his mom can sleep.
She's eating,
she sleeps at night.
She doesn't have pain
anymore or tumor shrinking.
The doctors are astounded.
Those stories,
you hear so many of them,
it's almost like they seem like
anecdotal fairy tales because until it's,
it happened to someone you actually know
and care about and then you go and then
you start getting angry.
Like,
this is what these God damn assholes
that are making laws in this country and
fighting against as the lobbyists and
the people that are working for the
pharmaceutical companies that are actively
trying to suppress this information.
You are keeping one of the best ways to,
to heal these people.
You're keeping it illegal and it's,
it's a fucking horrible crime
and they won't even tell you about it,
which is just atrocious.
They,
my dad is there giving my
brother the talk that my dad is,
is going to die and it's,
it's terminal and you know,
all this stuff for,
you know,
weeks and weeks and weeks.
He's going to the doctor.
And finally my brother's like,
hey,
so you know,
what about,
you know,
medical marijuana,
is that something that,
and they were like,
oh yeah,
we can prescribe him Marinol,
but we just can't,
you know,
there's no question that
the cannabis or Thc,
whatever it is,
uh,
cannabis helps fight cancer,
but we can't,
we can't refer.
You have to ask.
We can't just offer it to you.
And then they gave him that the,
uh,
prescription for Marinol,
which is like the government
pharmaceutical form of the pill,
which is probably where
weaker than the two year old.
And we were giving him,
yeah.
Not,
not nearly as good.
So yeah,
like we got the call,
I got the call from my dad or my
brother that my dad had passed away.
Um,
I think it was three weeks before the,
uh,
the Melvin Madoff fight.
And I flew home to,
um,
to Florida to,
you know,
kind of with my brother and sister and
figure out the situation where we were
going to do.
And my brother picked me up
from the airport and we went to,
you know,
straight to the bar to a,
have it out about my dad.
And,
um,
when we got back to his house,
my uncle had calls and you know,
we just assumed that my uncle was calling,
was going to give us his sorry to,
sorry about your dad.
And my sister answered the phone
and my uncle was hysterical.
And,
uh,
I guess my cousin Cody,
who was 23,
I was very close with
his huge fan of mine,
um,
had fallen off a balcony on their
vacation and died the same day.
And,
uh,
so it was,
it was a ton of stuff
to deal with that last,
you know,
two weeks for my fight.
And,
um,
again,
I talked to Vinny and,
uh,
you know,
he helped me stay focused
on what it needed to do,
do to handle business in that fight.
And,
uh,
you know,
of any Pharma can't think
of enough for that stuff,
that's
gotta be unbelievably difficult to do.
Both of those things.
Unbelievably difficult to deal with
while you're trying to focus on,
especially finding guy like
man holds a scary fuck,
you know,
every,
every post anybody tags for you and is
like Mo and Madoff's highlight reel.
It's like,
fuck it just,
it was tough,
you know,
and it just drains.
You haven't,
I tried to and come back and I got two
weeks left for the fight and I'm trying
to,
you know,
try to stay focused and,
uh,
you know,
I can run at a,
at a good clip and,
you know,
I run miles,
regularly and like,
I'd be like half a mile in and just be
exhausted because all of this mental
stuff just wears on you.
And,
uh,
you know,
I had this internal battle of myself,
if,
you know,
should I pull out of the fight
and not pull out of the fight?
And I talked to Vinny and I was like,
you know,
I just,
I don't know what to do.
And,
uh,
he was like,
he's just a dick actually.
He was like,
uh,
he was like,
your,
your dad and inner cousin died.
And I was like,
yes.
And he's like an and that,
that's sad.
And I'm like,
yes.
And he's like,
and,
uh,
you're never gonna see them again.
And I'm like,
yeah,
man,
I'm never gonna see him again.
He's like,
and that's not fair.
And I was like,
yeah,
motherfucker is not fair.
You know?
And he's like,
uh,
you know,
he says all this shit.
And then he's like,
now what?
And I was like,
what do you mean?
And he's like,
what are you going to do now?
And I was like,
he's like,
are you going to not ever fight again
and you gotta not to carry your family,
you're going to let this stop you from
everything you've ever wanted to do.
And I'm just like,
no.
And he's like putting in,
turn off that APP and wait until
after your fight handle your business.
You know,
whether you're religious or not at
some level somewhere you think your,
your cousin and your father,
what would they want?
And it was like,
well,
I talked to both of them about the fight.
They were both excited about the fight.
I knew what they were going to want.
So I just kind of turned off that
emotion until after the fight.
And when I knocked out Melvin,
there's like this,
this was this moment right after,
like the referee stops it at like fucking
explode and there's bullets worth post
the picture all the time.
But like at that moment was like all of
that emotion that I had turned off like
came back right at that moment.
And uh,
you know,
after the fight I was thinking about
them and stuff and it was really cool.
Wow.
That's intense.
But there's stuff that's an iconic photo
to the photo of you right after you
knocked him out.
It's a pretty intense photo.
That was a crazy fight too,
man.
It was a big one.
It was a big one from Calvin
is a wild motherfucker.
Dude.
Win,
lose,
draw that fucking you're,
you're in for some chaos with that guy.
Crazy.
Those all those guys from that mix jam.
Badr Hari Him.
[inaudible] there's so many of those guys.
Just fucking ferocious.
Yeah,
that's there,
that style out of that.
What I mean those,
that's why we're all there.
It is right there.
Yeah.
That was that moment right there.
Well,
we're running out of time,
man.
So let's end it with that.
That's a fucking perfect picture
to wrap this podcast up with.
That's intense
with Melvin down behind you.
You need that.
You gather on your gym.
Does that up on the wall?
Yeah.
I gotta put it up on the wall and shit.
Fucking for sure be up at the yard.
Yeah.